oh what oh she has a
contact named white chocolate
[Music]
hi hi hello all right this is one of
those progressive families where one
kid's black and one's what
adopted kids let's go that girl looks
like one of the characters in
big mouth
yeah why are you roasting her we just
started this video [ __ ] bro okay
go google black girl from big mouth and
put them side to side
tell me i'm lying tell me i'm lying
all right you guys in the comments you
guys letting me know has preach been
around why people for too long that now
he thinks we all look alike
or is he accurate let us know in the
comments below i just wanted to take a
second to appreciate we just started
this thing it immediately preached
just like you look like that girl from
the car too
who are you two and how do you know each
other i'm lex i'm john
it's my brother my name is ami my name
is lennon we're siblings this is my
sister
i'm nina i'm 23 and i'm sophie i'm 22.
and we are siblings unfortunately
you love each other maybe more recently
we did not used to like each other at
all how would you describe your
relationship
i'm 32 i'm 20. we don't spend a lot of
time together
alone i am actually adopted my parents
adopted me
and then they had her right after
current
relationship let's go through that
just sex now a text that they received
and then another one that just says sex
so i feel like the spicy stuff will be
way back
because now he's an old man hey so
there's an old picture of him
at a concert with his partner with his
wife
and he said that was a baller day love
that concert
tons of car sex too great
oh boy i need to be more careful but omg
i love to come inside of you
[Music]
i don't it's even funnier when you read
the conversation
do you know for sure actually i don't
know for sure but probably takes before
is like uh
i don't think i got pregnant i'm
assuming something about that because
afterwards he goes
i need to be more careful but oh my god
i'd love to come inside you
cream pie hard eyes but seriously how
did you like the sex
okay hey
hey you know what though he said i love
to come inside you there's a bunch of
guys all over the world who are just
like
and i notice this too as i get older it
feels better to do that
you know in my early days i was just
like don't want to be a daddy don't want
to be yet i pull out and i pull that
with the force
but as i get older you know what i mean
i start to pull that just a slight bit
slower and i'm like
maybe oh [ __ ] no no kids for me so
there's a progression that happens
over time hey you know what they say
it's almost like as your biological
clock moves into its prime
uh your body naturally is just like the
pull out game is no longer necessary the
force is leaving you you know what i'm
saying
no i think it's hey must be the monet
play on are you mad at that too
that's hey when you pour
when you pour pulling out is is birth
control for your bank account
you feel what i'm saying you get altered
when you get
go that's what it is bro once you get
rich it's almost like hitting menopause
you can just start busting everywhere
because there's no consequences
she said i can't walk and he said whoa
babe what on earth did you sleep wrong
i think it's my period plus sex plus
sleeping wrong is that a thing
pretty sure my sister is a virgin
he said i'm not taking this [ __ ] lying
down [ __ ] if you gonna expose my sex
secrets
i know you a virgin okay let's see some
photos
oh what is it it's um
hentai
how did you not know she was into anti
you look at the shulker
the toque how did you not know and i
knew that she's the type of girl to
write in her tinder profile i love
cowboy bebop you know what i'm saying
there's just a look to certain people
where you're like
and it's funny because the most she said
hentai looked at him like yeah sounds
about right
hentai is pretty much anime i hate to be
the one to have to explain that to
people who don't know but
there you go are you ready to swap with
your brother and have him go through
your phone
yeah she said that like somebody was
hiding 10 bodies
the way she was thinking he's like if he
finds anything he shouldn't
i'll kill him
she had to think about like he'll find
it
but he won't live to tell about it
it was the way that she thought about it
are you ready to swap with your brother
and have him go through your phone
[Laughter]
his wife lives 20 minutes away
what if he opened her phone and just
found out she was just like the biggest
city girl
taking all kinds of dicks blackmailing
dudes
talking to megan just talking to megan
the stallion on the weekend
you know what i'm saying hot girl summer
i'm witty i mean baby daddy's everywhere
what if he finds out the heck that the
reason why
his wife isn't walking well it's because
she's been [ __ ] her
[Music]
big dildo big pusa virgin now [ __ ]
what are you gonna look for i don't know
i don't think i'm gonna look for
anything i think i'm just gonna
go on a journey this guy does shroom on
a regular he sounds like he's doing acid
right now
i just wanna i just wanna go on a
journey because my mind is going through
a journey right now as we speak
have you ever tried ayahuasca a
life-changing experience
let me see if she has tinder yes she
does
i mean you're not gonna find much i
don't message people
hi i love tall girls and being
physically harmed i'll cosplay your
anime wife
[Music]
girls like this that's how you catch a
case don't even play with that
don't look at me like that that's a lot
more than i needed to know
this girl was judging her cause she
watched ty boo boo you live hentai
you live hentai you can start swiping on
people no
no don't do that he's not very
attractive
i'm gonna like him for you know what's
wrong with you
he matched that means he liked you first
poor guy is gonna be so
confused when i unmatch him oh what
oh she has a contact named
white
this is chocolate best one let's go hot
girl summer
city girls let's go i don't oh
i don't know it's gonna be on there you
were questioning
if she was a virgin or not i'm assuming
she is
she lives with my parents and so knowing
that
do you know any exes that any past
partners that she has
no i've i've never known her to date
anybody
yeah is this alexa make a moving
in-together board on pinterest
you're moving in with alexis yeah i'm so
excited about
it i didn't know she was moving out i
thought she was gonna live with our
parents forever
no yeah it's such a bad impression of
her
he doesn't even know well listen
no once you expose the whole cream pie
thing all bets are off
if you live at home and you live in that
basement i'm gonna tell them exactly
how long you haven't washed them sheets
for i'm gonna tell them how little you
shower
if you expose my sex life yeah so it's
done so
you can get this one it's time to go
oh you're getting on my ass about like
anime
and then there's like yuri on here what
it's like all anime characters
i think she was trying to pretend like
i'm the like weeboo of this
family but there's a lot of anime stuff
in here
uno reverse yo yo
no you pick a cards [ __ ] she swung and
punched herself
okay that's her ass oh dear god
why do you think sophie has an album of
her ass
some of these look like they're kind of
old so i would imagine she was sending
them to her ex test him
and text no no i do not hear her yelling
no
this producer he's a whole batman
villain
yes so how about you just dexter dexter
dexter x how about you just text her as
that
you miss him a whole lot huh do it and
if you can
send the picture of the ass to seal the
deal
no [ __ ] i'm gonna send this one her
boobs are out
like not fully but she has higher fat
green from jojo's was our adventure
edited over her shoulders
oh that one's not even sexy that's
depends what kind of guy you send that
to
i could assure you there's a bunch of
men if you sent a jojo reference with
your titties out they'd be like
yes yes
how about you and i we go on a bizarre
adventure you feel what i'm saying
let's go girl i'm gonna text her best
friend
to see if she finds me attractive oh my
gosh i've had
so many friends hit on my brother do you
want text-to-sex
anything she probably still has me
blocked
honestly what are you texting just a
broken heart oh if it delivers i'm gonna
be like uh
did it deliver nah oh
okay still blocked
she still hates me how was that that was
interesting
that went a lot better than i thought it
was going to go honestly you had more
girls trying to
get at you than i thought but ain't
[ __ ] i'm not
i didn't know you got played like that i
thought i thought you had one group of
five
damn you gotta play like a seven i mean
you know what it was in high school he
wasn't getting no [ __ ] i just thought
it was the same old same old what
is what it is thinking but apparently
you put it out you know what i mean hey
apparently you got some lesbians who
don't want to be lesbian that's
impressive bro
maybe you are six congratulations it was
definitely
painful i'm sorry what what his
wife is going through are you reading
those texts
i found stuff yeah you did i hate you
what did you discover hentai i have no
dignity
i mean i didn't really see anything that
really made me like oh i don't know this
guy who is he so i was just like okay
cool you know i actually know my brother
i honestly think we should
hang out more more yeah hang out more
yeah
there's always been this weird awkward
uh plexiglass between us yeah
wow i just noticed it yeah you know
alexis just texted you back
she's responding to the um do you find
me thank god brother hot
oh my gosh and she says what the [ __ ] no
not that fast oh that was fun i enjoyed
that
i enjoyed that one that was funny would
i ever let my siblings go through my
phone
i mean i wouldn't care i got nothing on
my phone my phone's dead dead
dead yeah so there's nothing much i've
never been one of those people without
incriminating stuff on the phone
uh people people don't send me nudes
because i tell them not to and i don't i
don't send people nudes i'm straight
and as far as like screenshots i have
it's just like like a picture of my feet
you have pictures of your feet yeah i
mean there's there's definitely pictures
of girls but like they're fully clothed
and like they're with people yeah
yeah you never do that like when you're
relaxing somewhere and someone's like
where are you you just take a picture of
your feet and where you're relaxing oh
when you're kicking them okay cool yeah
when i'm kicking them up when i'm
kicking them up
yeah hold on hold on hold on let me let
me send you an example
no i'm good thank you hold up let me
just give you an example i don't want to
see no pictures of your bunk ass feet
here you can see them right now go on
messenger check your phone i'm not doing
that
take your phone check your phone i'm not
going i promise this one has no crotch
action just
i don't care i'm not going i'm not doing
it okay i'm singing i'll just put it on
screen so this is what it looks like you
see you can see my feet
yeah i can see it perfectly
[Music]
that's it for today's video let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below if you guys enjoyed it
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
you